the class of Corona millions of students
around the world are graduating looking
for work in the middle of the biggest
economic collapse since the Great
Depression the lockdown generation could
become a lost generation some are using
their youth and energy to turn crisis
into opportunity what about the rest
[Music]
starting out in the business world can
be tough but many young entrepreneurs
receive no state support in some
countries I met others during this
crisis who have invested so much in new
ventures only to see it fizzle all away
for digital businesses it's a little
different
Soweto the former home of Nelson Mandela
is usually a tourist magnet
but since the coronavirus crisis the
streets have been cleared and the stores
closed standing in front of his empty
shop electrical to la cosa feels
completely helpless they might not be
tourists coming in here anymore
also who are we gonna sell to who gonna
make business with our business
basically looks like um it's coming to
and it looks like it's crashing down
yeah so that scares me a lot scares me
of cassano am I gonna feed my son it's a
devastating situation for young
entrepreneurs state support is only
available for large companies experts
predict youth unemployment will rise
even more this year but those who set up
digital business models before the
crisis are in a much better position to
ride out the shutdown like yoga teacher
and influenza TD Malo silico four years
ago TD Malo started to livestream her
daily practice sessions since the
lockdown her number of viewers has
skyrocketed
musician and I'm a yoga instructor and
both markets are interactive because
people are looking for music and some
people want to stay healthy so in
general for me I think it's been good
more so right now given code of 19 1000
people tuned in every day the training
sessions are free for everyone Judy ma
la earns money by promoting a clothing
label which she wears during the
sessions de Mello isn't the only one who
is making the most of her digital
business DJ Kue Jong is also exploring
the possibilities that live streaming
has to offer together with other artists
Kujo is developing a new commercial
format for live streaming gates he is
certain that this technology is a
growing trend that will last long after
the KO bids 19 crisis to him the
possibilities are endless I'm looking
forward to having like live concert big
concept live online concerts where you
can actually purchase a ticket and have
some kind of code that you put in there
just to get your your prod cast you know
and things are definitely going in that
in March South Africa's first cyber
party took place it was a huge success
will the lineup featuring many popular
musicians and DJs a mammoth 700 thousand
listeners tuned in to the online events
but for many young people who are losing
their income this offers little solace
expensive internet rates and poor
connectivity mean not everyone can
simply go digital still cosas in soweto
is trying to make the best of things
he started marketing his clothes over
what's up and Facebook
he says the crisis has made him rethink
the way he does business did has taught
me a lot of stuff especially when it
comes to getting out of your comfort
zone and trying and trying to make it
out there or trying to make something
out of nothing I think it's a it's all
about how you you you adapt to to the
situation that you're currently facing
there's still room for improvement he's
sold just two pieces so far but casa
says he won't let the virus win like
many others he's in this for the long
haul
so going digital is one way of surviving
but that won't apply to every single one
of the millions of graduates looking for
work while jobs are being slashed Oliver
Teixeira is a professor in resilience
research which is about overcoming
adversity in this case that adversity is
a virus will there forever be a stigma
attached to the class of 2020 Oliver
well I don't think so what we actually
have learned through this crisis by
asking people is that they actually do
overcome this crisis very well although
a lot of people do actually feel the
burden and do have a little dip in their
mental well-being most of the people
actually come through the crisis in a
good way and find ways to manage the
crisis it's even what we do see is that
in terms of schooling that the graduates
have at least as good as as good grades
as before even better
it's what we've learned just now what if
you're one of the graduates who is
struggling if you want that sort of
person who thrives on stress
there's obviously there is a group
actually it's about twenty to thirty
percent of people where we know from
other resilience studies as well who
don't actually aren't that good as in
the managing crisis and for those people
we can say that the good news is that
resilience or actually overcoming
problems is learnable so you can
actually learn about how to repress
things in a more positive way to
regulate the emotions and overcome
stress in many ways and we have actually
developed programs in our lab nest
Institute for resilience research which
you can find online to do so how I don't
want you to take us through the whole
course but how do you develop resilience
its many abilities as humans one one
important one we have actually looked at
is the so called whip being able to do
positive reappraisal so let's say for
this corona crisis there's a lot of
problems from the lockdown
obviously for and not being able to go
into school but on the other hand people
got time by not commuting or not doing
other things to actually sit down and
learn and that obviously helped them to
overcome this obstacle so that's that's
one way and the other and to look at
this in a positive way that's one way
the other way is to to being optimistic
on your future to seek help from others
social support it's a very important
thing so be in touch with others helps
you coming through crisis and and
there's also something we would say are
we call acceptance right so if we accept
this is crisis is hitting everyone it's
complex you can't change it yourself
you can do a lot for yourself and others
to come through in a good way that will
help you to develop resilience it's good
to hear some something positive in this
crisis Oliver toosha a professor of
resilience research thank you very much
time to visit Derek Williams in his home
office we've had our science
correspondent locked up there since the
beginning of the crisis researching your
questions on the corona virus is
reinfection possible research on this
topic while ongoing is is still
inconclusive and will likely continue to
be so for some months to come but a
certain amount of what's called outlier
reinfection with kovat 19 is actually to
be expected not not everyone who catches
the virus will mount a strong immune
response and and we know that repeat
infections do occur with other corona
viruses there are also a number of
reasons why someone who tests positive
once for an infectious disease can
retest positive a few months after their
symptoms improve including the chance
that they never really shook off the
infection the first time around I think
the key question here is not about
whether reinfection can happen it's
about it's about scale if we start to
see significant numbers of people who
had coded 19 once beginning to come down
with it again then that'll be the time
to really worry but but up until now the
number of possible re-infections has
remained has remained scattered and
quite low actually and that's good
because we're so focused on the pandemic
we can be pretty sure that we're seeing
most of them and the longer the numbers
stay low the better
does chlorine dioxide help prevent the
disease or help you recover from it
chlorine dioxide is another substance
being touted in South America especially
as a miracle cure for kovat 19 the
compound has been sold on the fringes of
the internet for years as a purported
treatment for everything from cancer to
to autism many national health
authorities have issued warnings about
its dangers but in cities that have been
hit by the virus in Bolivia in
particular the idea that it can prevent
or cure kovat 19 has gained traction and
and people are lining up to buy it
chlorine dioxide is an industrial bleach
that can be toxic when ingested and
there have been many reports of people
poisoning themselves with it after
taking it you can develop symptoms that
include
severe vomiting and diarrhea acute low
blood pressure from dehydration and and
acute liver failure there's currently no
scientific evidence at all that the
bleaching agent can prevent or treat
covin 19
[Music]